this video released by the pentagon
shows a raid on the compound of the
islamic state's ideological leader and
founder abu bakar
al-baghdadi it resulted in his death and
marked one of the biggest defeats for
the militant group known as isis
he died after running into a dead end
tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way his successor was announced just
days later
was not the first major loss isis had
suffered
this is all isis now on the bottom
that's as of today this is isis there's
none
the caliphate is gone as of tonight
that was a massive setback for the
physical caliphate that had for years
spread its brutal regime of terror
across
large areas of iraq and syria
but as officials at the time warned that
wasn't the end of the militant group
this is not the end of the fight against
isis isis still lives on in various
cells and in the minds of many of the
people
uh in the areas that we've liberated
but that victory did not do was destroy
isis as a military force
jennifer cafarella is a syria and isis
specialist and one of the authors of
isis's second comeback
it's an assessment that uses
declassified information and research
to develop a picture of the next isis
resurgence
isis had already dispersed into
populated areas
as well as ungoverned spaces like the
syrian desert in central syria
to regroup and return to an offensive
campaign as an insurgency
following the defeat of the physical
caliphate was a string of attacks
[Music]
several in afghanistan including one on
a government building that killed seven
but the biggest of the attacks was the
so-called easter bombings in sri lanka
where a series of blasts killed more
than 300 people
just a few days after that there was a
call from its now deceased leader to
redouble efforts and further the
extremist group's cause around the world
so we saw several messages from baghdad
and others really urging people to
continue
promising the return of some form of the
islamic state
we started hearing about attacks being
inspired we heard about funding going to
places like
afghanistan to sort of expand the
caliphate in that way
but as the group continued to spread its
ideology globally
a decision by president trump to pull
u.s forces out of syria shocked the
region
intensifying the fear of a physical isis
resurgence
the worst thing any commander-in-chief
can do to the soldiers
is to give back to the enemy land taken
through blood and sacrifice
as the u.s left turkey and
turkish-backed forces advanced into
syria seizing territory held by kurdish
forces
those same kurdish forces guarding some
prison camps and detention centers
holding isis
prisoners and family members linked to
islamic state
according to syrian democratic forces or
sdf there are just over 12
000 isis fighters in detention including
more than 2 000
foreign fighters and estimates from u.s
forces on the ground
say there are tens of thousands of isis
family members scattered across
internally displaced people camps or
idps
what you can see here in red are
facilities from which isis has succeeded
or attempted
to break out family members and fighters
from prisons
now those breakouts thus far are not
highly coordinated
so we're talking about riots and small
levels of isis members paying bribes
essentially to guards
so that they can escape or be smuggled
out of these facilities
while turkish president rajit tayyip
erdogan assured trump he would secure
the prisons inside the proposed safe
zone some of the most important ones
are located outside of that and it's not
just the prisons under threat
the instability in syria is a major
concern for neighbouring iraq
on both sides in syria here and on the
iraqi side
this is ungoverned desert now there are
small pockets of the border essentially
that the iraqis are securing
but the rest of this is essentially
desert and therefore isis can traverse
it
there are also concerns that the other
players in the region involved don't
have
any interest in keeping isis at bay the
u.s withdrawal from northeast syria
creates a security vacuum
and multiple actors are now going to
compete with military force
to fill that vacuum all of the other
actors in this region
are fighting in syria for different
goals that they prioritize
far and above beyond the threat from
isis and frankly that includes the kurds
we've accelerated basically the
disintegration
of the unity of effort against isis that
only the united states was able to
create
but how concerned should we be with
these threats
and what might an isis resurgence look
like what one has to watch for is
how they sort of try to reconstitute or
rebuild or rebrand themselves in a way
such that they
have learned from those lessons and are
able to endure longer
as a caulifla than they were the first
time i don't have the imagination to
tell you how that's going to go
but that ideology remains a powerful one
and one that inspires a lot of people
and one that is expansive and worldwide
the global isis expansion has included
adding
new formal provinces to the isis
structure we have seen
a redoubling of that isis effort to
expand in northern africa
and now an expansion farther south to
the drc
and other central african states we've
simultaneously seen an expansion in the
east asia regions
isis has had a province in afghanistan
since early in the caliphate but has now
expanded
to include a separate province in
pakistan and a separate province in
india
these isis provinces are in addition to
what isis calls the east asia province
based in the philippines where isis had
achieved a major success
in 2017 seizing the provincial capital
of marawi
and defending it against the philippine
security forces
for a number of weeks we've never had a
terror group resurrect itself
in the same form these groups have a way
of metastasizing and reconstituting
themselves in ways that perhaps we don't
always have the imagination to foresee
they still have millions of dollars in
revenue not nearly to the levels that
they did at their peak
when we think about the future of isis i
think it's really important
to not be confined to that box of
thinking of what it was in 2014 2015
2016
or to think of collapse strictly in the
form of the physical caliphate because
that virtual health fit is as important
and arguably will be key to however it
reconstitutes itself if it's able to